تنظيم حسان ساعات وهي تحرك قدر اليقطين
فالمونه التي تحضرها ليست للاستخدام
المنزلي بل يتم توزيعها على عائلات محتاجه
خلال الشهر الصوم وام حسان ليست افضل حالا
فهي المعيله الوحيده لثلاثه اطفال لجات
الى تعاونيه الخياره التي تعمل على تمكين
المراه التي تؤمن مصدر رزق يتماشى مع
دورها كربه منزل الاب للاولاد مش موجود
والوضع الاقتصادي
ومجبوره انا ما فيش غيري انا قدام الاولاد
يعني انا
الباي والام يعني اعمل الدوران تواصلنا مع
جمعيات بتوعنا بسلامه الغذاء وخضعوا
السوايا عنا كلياتهم لتدريبات نحن عندنا
16 ست بالتعاونيه وبلشنا نشتغل على
التصنيع المونه البيتيه والكيترنج
وهالشيء هيدا كليته يساعد الصبايا انه
بلشت تطلع من تتعلمت على مون جديده على
تصنيع جديد بنقل غذاء اللبناني الذي يكثف
من مساعداته الغذائيه خلال الشهر الصوم
اختار تعاونيه الخيار لتامين الحصص
التموينيه للعائلات المحتاجه
وبذلك يكون قد ساعد ايضا النسوه القرويه
اما المنتوجات فتامنها تعاونيه الخياره من
المزارعين اللبنانيين لتساعدهم ايضا على
تصريف محاصيلهم الزراعيه
بسنه 23
الطلبات للمساعدات كثير كثرت والجمعيات ما
بقى تقدر تتحمل عدد الاشخاص اللي طالبه
مساعدات بالمقابله لمساعدات اللي كنت
تجينا من خارج لبنان ومن لبنان كتير قلت
فعم بيكون عنا كتير صعوبات لنقدر نوفي او
نوفر
مساعدات لكل العالم اللي عم تقدم طلب
جربنا قد ما فينا بدعم من عده متبرعين
نحافظ على العدد اللي راح يقدر يستفيد
منها هذا الشهر
1250 عائله لبنانيه ستستفيد من صناديق
تحتوي على مونه قرويه لبنانيه كما وسيؤمن
بنك الغذاء ايضا وجبات افطار طيله شهر
الصيام من خيرات الارض في القرى الى
العائلات المحتاجه في المدن اطلق مايك
الغذاء اللبناني حمله جديده من التبرعات
لمساعده العدد الاكبر من الاسر خلال الشهر
رمضان المبارك غنوا يتيم العربيه البقاع